last week the Tennessee legislature
passed its Bill Banning drag shows for
children actually it bans all sexual
performances in front of children the
bill uses the phrase adult Cabaret and
drag is not especially singled out or
even specifically mentioned drag queens
have felt personally targeted simply
because they happen to be the only ones
who want to perform sexually for
children the law forbids anyone and
everyone from engaging in sexualized
displays in the site of minors we are
all equally restricted strip clubs
saying damn we wanted kids in here damn
we wanted to do topless pole dances at
the kindergarten parade you don't see
that happening why have you seen some of
the footage of these of these drag
queens dancing and underwear in front of
children looks like a good time and a
lot of times there's parents and they're
like and they're laughing and clapping
and I'm like what goes on in your house
if you're if you're comfortable
sexualizing your children in public have
you ever been to address what goes on
behind the scenes would you ever go to
one um I've been to one it's
entertaining it's adults there's alcohol
not for kids yeah it's not for children
it is very sexy I went to one too I
wasn't a fan though not my cup of tea I
went for like a it was a birthday
weekend for a friend in Vegas and I just
went along with to whatever the crowd
was like she had her whole all like 20
of us and I was just going along and I
was like yeah this is fine we had a
great time we had a lot of laughs it was
fine it was for adults girls trip
all right I won't go to one area now and
again though because now the the trans
Community has turned me off so much and
it's sad because not there's really only
a part of them that are into kids no I
can't be going a direction you know but
they've gone too far and I I'm just I'm
I'm out I'm sorry I have no interest
anyways area now in Tennessee but the
difference is that the rest of us have
no desire to do such a thing uh we are
repulsed by the very thought of it many
drag queens apparently do have this
desire and so they complain that they're
being especially oppressed by this I
couldn't imagine being like a like a
human being like this person's a living
organism that like wants to do that in
front of kids or like wood that seems
like a dare where it's like I would
never do that or like a bunch of money I
wouldn't I wouldn't like dress up like a
girl and shake my ass in front of kids
that seems like one of those things that
it's like I would never do it's deprived
it's crazy bringing sex in front of
children is depraved and sick and we've
always been protected children from it
now we're bigots for doing that yeah
okay pero now the days since the Bill's
passing the media has published one sob
story after another telling us about the
horrible plight of Tennessee drag queens
who fear that they may never be able to
perform a striptease for elementary
schoolers ever again and that really
really uh is a tragic thing for them
it's real Business Insider just
published an interview with local drag
queen Bella dubal and this is the same
man who as we heard last week gave a
speech at a recent drag event
threatening violence and riots if the
ban on child sexualization is passed
um he uh you know insinuated that if
he's not able to
sexually perform in front of a child
then he might start smashing people with
bricks that's how important it is to him
that he's able to do this now that it is
passed um even though he was the one
threatening violence he now says that he
fears for his life here's the inside
report back before we see him I want to
see this person his name is Bella uh you
know what Bella means in Italian right
beautiful beautiful so this is just a
this is just a freak Reality 99 out of
100 times and there's a young a girl or
a woman named Bella bro I don't know
anything looks like she got beat with
the ugly stick it's really ironic and
unusual in reality so now I'm curious
what this Bella I never thought about
that till just now but that is so true
so crazy and sad like which looking fat
Bella like like you got to be real
careful what you name your kid you got
to look around the family and go what
are the chances that this Bell is going
to actually be Bella an interview with
Insider the ball called the bill
terrifying and said she's personally
afraid for her own safety notice the
female pronouns by the way they were
using for drag queens who don't even say
that they identify as women
but are but are you know putting on a
character and so they're referring to
the character as if the character exists
in real life in the article
um it's like if there was a if there was
an interview with Joaquin Phoenix and
the interviewer referred to him as the
Joker in the article
the bill specifies that a second offense
would be considered a classy felony
which carries a jail sentence of up to
six years
quote I could go to prison for six years
for appearing in a public Shake in your
junk in front of little kids this isn't
hard that that's terrifies her that she
can't do that yeah this doesn't really
sound real but it is real and these
people are so delusional like so out
this guy this part
they should have the right to do this
belongs in an insane asylum I'm scared
that if I'm wearing gender
non-conforming clothing in Kroger and
someone has their kids and they clutch
them tight and call the cops I could get
arrested just for presenting that way in
my daily life
quote there has never there's never once
been a child who has been sexually
assaulted or harmed at a drag show or a
pride performance so every time you get
a child used to being sexualized in
front of them you take them you take
away one layer of protection from that
child when somebody is then going in to
sexually assault them you take away that
Nat you you break down that natural
instinct to go uh this is wrong this
feels wrong yeah and you break down
their instincts it's evil so yeah you
are taking your child one class one step
closer even if you haven't done it
yourself ride performance if there had
been it would be a poster image for
their campaign we would see it
everywhere
now of course as we know these people
lie about everything all the time and
he's lying here yes the law would not
result in him getting carted away in
handcuffs if he cross-dressed at Kroger
as much as that thought might be please
I always say [__] like that whenever
there's some new law or something like
that's the same thing they say with
abortion every time like if your 14 year
old daughter got raped you wouldn't want
her to be able to to get rid of it
that's what they say every time and it's
like bro you're acting like 99.9 of
abortions aren't just hoes being hoes
right they always appreciate stupid 99
babies to justify one and it's and it's
less than one but yeah you're right to
some of us
um that's not what would actually happen
this law specifically Outlaws sexual
performances
so unless he's in the produce section
twerking on the avocados he probably
doesn't have much to worry about in that
regard now as for the claim that no
child has ever been assaulted or harmed
at a drag show
what he means is that there's been
no video of a child being physically
molested by a drag queen on camera
during the performance
because anything outside of that
doesn't count as assault or harm
apparently according to him one of the
things that I've learned a lot about in
the past couple years is discipline get
control of your head control your mind
and learn discipline and so you stop
talking yourself out of things and so
you know Tom Shea the Navy SEAL who we
work with I went through his 21 day
challenge where he gave me some tasks to
do every day and part of the challenge
was to wake up every day commit to doing
it and every time I started to talk
myself out of it I would have an excuse
run through my head some lame ass excuse
and there are four main excuses that he
teaches people that are that ruin lives
that's why we're doing the 21 Day
Challenge again together which Sunny is
not excited about because he's going to
have Tom on his ass if you guys actually
would like to do that with us go to the
link in the description because there's
a discount code come and do it because
guaranteed in one area of your life
there's something you're not doing
because you talk yourself out of it
every day you can go to the top of the
description click the link and buy it
with code Sunny fast50 for a nice
discount and we'll be doing you know
with you guys will be in the zoom calls
and everything it'll be cool the adult
needs to be protected from from pronouns
that scare him the child doesn't need to
be protected from even R-rated sex shows
according to this guy
this is why these people see it they
want us to see it that way but it is of
course totally wrong
in fact there is video evidence of
children being harmed at drag shows
trying to get such a blowback like there
it people are only now just starting to
come out of the woodwork and speak up
about this now people like Matt Walsh
with a platform they are you know they
are out they are touring the country
speaking about it is this a real problem
is this that big of a problem it is a
big yes apart yes it is a problem they
are doing this they are Transit kids in
schools they have teachers in some
places able to where children that's
different yes but it it's all this is
all in the same bucket part of that
transient kids in schools is bringing in
this entertainment to make it seem like
this is normal yeah no I agree because
they do it in Little Steps but it's only
this it's only this oh my God you're
just gonna get mad at me I'm not hurting
anybody and the next thing you know your
kid is cutting off his penis I got a
call today from a friend who was we
always differed politically I was always
more right she was you know like a
moderate leftist we haven't spoken in a
couple of years and we talked today day
and she was like I am done she goes I
couldn't stand Donald Trump she goes but
you can bet that he's got my vote if he
runs there's no way I'm putting Biden
back in all this [__] and she was
talking about the economy and the
transiting of the kids and the CRT and
all the racism and all the stuff and
she's out of her mind she's like I can't
believe what they're allowing to go on
and what's happening I feel like I'm in
the what did you I feel like I feel like
I'm in the upside down world I said the
dormergogen would be easier to deal with
than this [__] yeah I feel like you
have to be crazy to be a leftist
nowadays to be honest yeah like I really
just don't understand it it gave me so
much hope though that somebody yeah
would come out and be like no she's
she's still not being public about it
because yeah even though it's not as bad
to be public about any anymore like I I
say whatever I want I don't give a [__]
right but but a lot of people are just
now starting to even say that to their
friends okay listen here's the truth
I've had it and these people have no
idea once everybody starts speaking up
it's all going to hell for them they can
all go back into their dark little caves
where they belong every single child
who's ever attended one has been harmed
they are all abuse victims this is
abusive inherently by its nature to
involve children in something like this
indeed and the abusers are only becoming
more Brazen about it case in point
footage has gone viral this week of a
show called
Kaba Baba Rave now this is a uh look at
this oh my God mommies and babies as you
might pick up from the name a cabaret
Rave what is going on what happened to
taking your kid to a Barney show
that is meant for babies
yes babies oh oh
it is a touring show that goes from
place to place
performing sexual Cabaret for babies and
toddlers
here's an article on the British website
called the mank I've said it before and
I'll say you know I don't get like they
hate men these leftists hate men except
when the men pretend to be women that's
that's the only time it's okay to be a
guy or a white guy if you pretend to be
a girl yeah and then and then they're
like the feelings the feelings and then
they'll like come and shake your schlong
for my baby yeah and my daughter I don't
know like everyone in that room I'd
rather everyone in that room needs to go
into the Asylum together they all are
just disgusting people I'm sorry you
take your kid to that I'd rather they
just hated all the white men and then
this [__] wouldn't happen I've done some
dumb [__] as a mother but my God quote a
cabaret Rave sensory experience
especially for babies and toddlers is
coming to Manchester later this year the
tickets are now on sale our city region
may never be short of unique events and
interesting things to be getting up to
but kabba Baba Rave is gearing up to be
unlike anything else on offer for little
manx and their parents she's bringing
the experience of a big London night out
to a popular social club uh this October
it's described as being a little slice
of Afternoon Delight that provides
show-stopping Cabaret interspersed with
baby sensory moments
and if that all wasn't captivating
enough as it is each session ends in a
rave okay so Afternoon Delight is a song
from the 70s about fooling around in the
afternoon I I don't I don't even I don't
even know what to say to that ABBA Baba
Rave is hosted by Lizzy and Gemma two
performers turned moms who were
constantly looking to be entertained
whilst holding a baby in one hand and a
pint in another
yes baby sensory moments is the
euphemism that they're using here
and if you're hearing about all this and
you're thinking to yourself well wait a
minute no way this we must be missing
something there's just no way that this
can be what it sounds like I refuse to
believe that something like this exists
a cabaret Rave for babies
well the footage of one of these events
should wake you up to the horrifying
reality it is very real
and as you can see he's put the images
up on the screen there are parents
sitting around with their babies and
toddlers
watching as men in bondage gear swing
around on ropes
they look like a whole lot of Bellas
I'll tell you that look at the smiles on
these people's faces the dad dad's there
do you think that you're so woke and so
wonderful and you're contributing to
society this is what absolute
selfishness and focus on oneself and a
complete absence of God it looks like
this is what that looks like and even if
you don't believe in God and you believe
in you know Karma and it's a bigger
force of energy or even if you don't
believe in any of that what do you
believe in if this is how you're
spending your time oh this is so gross
Bros hairy legs this thing whatever this
dude this dude likes to get pegged for
sure there's another man in a in a
wearing a thong and nothing else and
doing a handstand and spreading his legs
doing all of this for babies and
toddlers there are half naked adults uh
adults twerking
this is a full-on R-rated sex show
targeted at children three and under
that's what it is thank God this is
disgusting they're not going to remember
it this is disgusting it's disgusting oh
my God don't judge again these are
though the same people who say if you
say anything harsh to your child that
they they're going to need therapy
forever but you could have a grown man
shaking his fake boobies in your baby's
face and that's that's not gonna leave a
mark what's their logic like what what's
their reasoning I don't know they want
to teach their children to be inclusive
of pedophiles is that the is that what's
the logic like what could it be Let's
Pretend We're nuts [__] Brits doing
this and not that they're not here in
America too no offense Brits I don't
know like let's pretend I guess just
people I guess just inclusivity and
wokeness like showing them that you
don't have to be cisgender you know what
the thing is like you know that the
girls that are like I don't ever want to
have kids and then it's like you know
you don't have to be straight and all
this and it's like bro if everyone
thought like you the world would be over
in 80 years right well it's also you
telling you since you since you were a
little kid and it's time for you to hear
it again because it's been a while what
you want when you're seven you're not
gonna want when you're 10. you're going
to continue to change and grow and
change and grow I continue to change and
grow I don't even want what I wanted two
years ago yeah even a year ago and so
the things you want now you're you're
not going to want in a year and you're
going to continue to change and grow and
so you know when they have these girls
at 12 going I don't want to be a boy I
don't want I mean I don't want to be a
girl and I don't want to have kids so
let's start cutting off my body parts
why aren't parents having a conversation
with them and saying honey listen
remember when you were five and you were
really into uh you know Barbie dolls and
then by the time you were eight you
weren't and you were into gymnastics and
uh you know hair ties or you know
braiding or whatever and then you like
take the child on on its own journey and
remind it of how it has changed that's
what you do instead of just giving into
whims like you're talking about I don't
want to have kids yeah I'm sure if
everyone I don't want these people to
have any more kids either if this is
what they're going to do they're going
to create little lunatic future
pedophiles yeah no no complaints there
if they don't and it's as I said been
going on for a while Kaba Baba Rave has
been um hosting sold out shows for
months sold out shows without anyone
objects them or at least without the
sorts of people who would object finding
out about it
now that we have found out about it the
groomers behind Kaba Baba Rave have
locked everything down they've gone into
hiding basically at least uh you know in
cyberspace
um the website has been taken down the
Instagram Facebook page all that has
been turned private and this happened
the moment that
these images of footage
emerged on social media and people like
normal people saw this they shut
everything down
this statement just to let our followers
know we've turned out we've turned to
shut all your stuff down no it seems
illegal for them to do that like to host
that event well it is in Tennessee now
we've been subject to a pretty horrific
trolling attack and it just keeps coming
as mothers with young Toddlers and one
of us heavily pregnant this has become
more stressed than we're able to deal
with right now these trolls specifically
have a problem with drag artists and
non-binary performers performing for
children which is exceptionally sad as
those of us who have been uh who have
been who those who have been to our
event will know how much joy love and
happiness our shows bring
oh they are the victims of course they
think what a surprise
now
why is this happening I mean what is the
motive motivation for the adults
involved
well there's a lot going on we can
assume that the performers are perverts
who get a sexual thrill out of exposing
themselves to children
parents are sick twisted freaks who
signal their allegiance to the woke
religion by offering up their children
in this way making a sacrifice of their
children's innocence for some of them it
might also be um as well more of a
selfish disregard
um I mean it's selfish regard across the
board but they're also they're also
parents who who personally want to
attend these kinds of performances and
they bring their kids along because they
don't really care what effect it will
have on the kids and then for All the
Above
there's also the overarching intention
to desensitize and confuse children to
induct them into the less sexual
pathologies and obsessions from a very
young age to groom them in other words
so there are varied motivations for all
these adults but one thing that they
have in common
is that they should all be sitting in a
prison cell right now and we will know
that we have restored some semblance of
sanity and dignity in our culture when
but not until we start seeing Law
Enforcement Officers swarming these
kinds of events handcuffing every adult
in the room and frog marching them out
of the building and into a prison cell
okay you could take the drag perverts in
their thongs and just throw them right
into jail we'll see how um sexually
expressive they want to be in that
environment yeah and then you take the
kids away from the parents and you throw
the parents into jail right alongside
them yeah
yeah yes that's how we have to respond
yes because these perverts are not going
to stop on their own
they will only get more brazen
we have to stop them agreed that he's
doing this I love that he's out here
this guy must need 24 7 like retired
Special Forces as his security this guy
what are the what are the soy people
gonna do no they're a lot of nuts you
don't have to they're a lot of nuts and
that's why we need every Republican
presidential candidate in 2024 to
promise a federal ban on these child
drag shows okay kids in Tennessee are
protected now
but all children deserve the same
protection
we cannot be satisfied with a few
legislative victories in a few States
those are very good those are good
things that's a step but it's only a
step in the process and just as the ban
on child gender transitions must go
Federal
so must the law against this kind of
Genesee
the other side they're only getting more
bold
more Brazen more extreme
we have to meet them with that same
energy
an absolute zero tolerance policy it's
so funny I was talking with me and my
friends about like the transgender [__]
we were all saying how like in high
school we were all like not more like
pro-it but like just like completely
fine with it like it's totally you know
it's all cool like they have it when
they shove it down your throat non-stop
you you come to think like this is the
new reality this is the norm like it's
okay and then once you leave and you
start like watching different type of
content and interacting with different
people and then you look at it again and
you're like none of this makes any sense
and like this is what they were shoving
down our throats in school it's very
interesting to see like the mindset
changes and even like some of my more
liberal friends coming out of high
school I'm glad I'm glad that your
friend you're generation is seeing it
but I told you I I but even though I
grew up in Brooklyn right we went into
the city all the time we're always and
you drove through the village man and
there were dudes and dresses just
walking down the street it was normal it
was always there so I saw it from the
time I was a little girl I never thought
it you saw it in Boston do you remember
the time on the train seeing the man in
the dress yeah yeah
um you looked confused and I was like
yeah some people like that like I didn't
teach you anything about how to feel I
just said this is some men do you feel
dressed like that you know and I never
had a problem with it in all my long
years and now they can all go to hell
because now they've come after the
children and they can all go scratch
their asses and go back to their like I
said their dark Corners I don't give a
[__] inclusive my ass for groomers
that's the only way for them wow that
was great finish man good thing we did
that yeah you know everything all right
thanks for watching guys join the
Discord drop a sub hit like it doesn't
like when I do it you know what nobody
cares
[Music]